en el vídeo anterior nos quedamos a la
mitad de un ejercicio de triángulos
semejantes teníamos dos rectas paralelas
les trazamos dos transversales y se
formaron dos triángulos estábamos a
punto de ver que esos dos triángulos
eran semejantes y eso nos iba a servir
para encontrar la longitud de estos dos
segmentos de acá lo que ya habíamos
hecho era mostrar que este ángulo es
igual a este ángulo de acá porque son
opuestos por el vértice y lo que dijimos
es que en este vídeo y vamos a
justificar por qué este ángulo naranja
es igual a este de acá y este ángulo
rojo es igual a este de acá entonces
vamos a hacer justo eso deja de tomar el
color naranja y lo que vamos a hacer
primero es justificar que este ángulo
que es más dejar de ponerle doble rayita
naranja es congruente a este ángulo de
acá bueno pues eso se debe justo a que
estas dos rectas son paralelas estos dos
ángulos son alternos internos pero bueno
si no te quieres acordar de los ángulos
alternos internos puedes darte cuenta
que este ángulo es correspondiente con
este ángulo de acá
con esta pareja de rectas y está
transversal y ahora estos dos ángulos
son opuestos por el vértice entonces
este ángulo es congruente a este de acá
eso es algo muy bonito de las
matemáticas verdad a veces no nos
tenemos que memorizar todo puede ser que
solo al memorizar nos unas pequeñas
cosas podamos deducir las demás bueno
eso justifica la congruencia de estos
dos ángulos y de manera similar podemos
justificar la congruencia de este ángulo
rojo que lo voy a marcar así triple con
este ángulo rojo de acá entonces eso
justo nos dice que estos dos triángulos
son semejantes porque tienen sus tres
ángulos congruentes en realidad basta va
a verificar sólo dos como lo vimos en el
vídeo anterior bueno ahora si queremos
encontrar esta longitud de acá déjame
llamarle x vamos a ponerle x y para eso
vamos a utilizar estos dos triángulos
semejantes entonces veamos cómo le
tenemos que hacer observemos que x o
esta longitud corresponde al segmento
que es opuesto a este ángulo
déjame marcarlo así fuerte en color rojo
entonces este segmento es opuesto a este
ángulo de acá de modo que es
correspondiente con este lado de acá con
el que es también opuesto al ángulo en
rojo al ángulo triple entonces tenemos
que este segmento es correspondiente a
este de acá y observa que este que mide
5 es opuesto al ángulo naranja
y por lo tanto es correspondiente a este
de acá al que mide 4 porque también en
este triángulo en el pequeño es opuesto
al ángulo naranja déjame marcar unas
flechitas entonces este es
correspondiente a este este a este igual
con los rojos este de acá este segmento
corresponde a este ángulo y este de acá
a esta corresponde a este ángulo de acá
listo entonces con esto ya podemos
utilizar la semejanza de los dos
triángulos para encontrar el valor de x
cómo le hacemos pues tenemos que x entre
no voy a poner así x dividido entre 4 es
igual a o más bien déjame déjame hacer
la división de esta forma lo voy a hacer
con las dos correspondientes x entre 6
para que todo quede en color rojo x
entre 6 es igual a pues en la razón
entre los lados correspondientes que
sería este de 4 o sea es igual a 4
dividido entre 5
entre 5 entonces para encontrar el valor
de x multiplicamos por 6 de ambos lados
y nos queda que x es igual
a 24 dividido entre 5 muy bien eso nos
da esta longitud 24 dividido entre 5 y
de hecho también podemos calcular esta
longitud de acá la voy a pintar en color
amarillo porque es opuesta a este ángulo
amarillo y en el triángulo de abajo este
segmento que también estoy pintando en
amarillo es el correspondiente a este de
acá a este ángulo
entonces si a este le ponemos por
ejemplo podemos también calcular el
valor de y cómo le hacemos pues una vez
más hacemos la razón entre lados
correspondientes y entre 8 ya dividido
entre 8 es igual a y podemos utilizar
los naranjas o los rojos pero si usamos
los rojos nos queda 24 quintos entre 6
que es un número muy feo entonces
podemos utilizar cuatro quintos otra vez
entonces ya entre 8 es igual a cuatro
quintos multiplicando por 8 de ambos
lados obtenemos que que es igual a 32
quintos y entonces ya es igual es igual
a 32
treinta y dos quintos muy bien vamos a
hacer otro problema más déjame bajar
para tener un poco más de espacio
una vez más voy a empezar con dos rectas
paralelas las voy a pintar en color
blanco entonces aquí va una recta y aquí
va una recta paralela
ok y lo que vamos a hacer es otra vez
construir dos transversales pero que
ahora se intersectan por acá los voy a
pintar en color morado y van a ser más o
menos así y así
y así sale entonces ahí tenemos estas
dos transversales que se cortan en este
punto de acá y lo que queremos hacer
ahora es mostrar que este triángulo
pequeño déjame pintarlo en otro color en
color azul este triángulo pequeño
queremos ver que es semejante al
triángulo grande que se forma a este
triángulo que tiene este vértice este
vértice y este vértice de acá bueno
habrá algún ángulo que que evidentemente
compartan pues si notemos que el ángulo
en este vértice es un ángulo
correspondiente a esos dos triángulos
es un ángulo que está en el triángulo
pequeño y es un ángulo que está en el
triángulo grandote así que déjame
marcarlo en color amarillo este ángulo
es parte de los dos triángulos hay
algunos otros ángulos que podamos ver
que son iguales que sean congruentes
pues sí como tenemos que está recta es
paralela a esta de acá hay un montón de
ángulos correspondientes por ejemplo
este ángulo que voy a marcar en verde y
con dos rayitas es un ángulo
correspondiente a éste
a este de acá sale y de manera similar
este ángulo que voy a pintar en morado y
que le voy a poner tres rayitas es
congruente a este ángulo de acá a este
ángulo de acá
entonces eso muestra que estos dos
triángulos tienen exactamente los mismos
ángulos el amarillo el verde y el morado
en el grande también verdad el amarillo
el verde y el morado y por lo tanto son
triángulos semejantes así que ahora
podemos jugar un poco con esa semejanza
imagínate que sabemos que este lado de
acá mide 5 que este lado de acá mide 7
que este lado de acá mide 6
dale déjame ser un poco más claro con
quienes estoy acá es el que mide 6 este
de acá es el que mide 5 y estoy acá es
el que mide 7 sale e imagínate que
también sabemos que este lado grandote
que este lado grandote de acá mide 12
mide 12 y que queremos determinar la
longitud de este lado de acá de este
lado de acá vamos a ponerle así entre
signo de interrogación x ok entonces
como le haríamos para determinar el
valor de x bueno pues ya conocemos o ya
sabemos que estos dos triángulos son
semejantes y sabemos exactamente cuáles
son sus lados correspondientes
este lado de aquí déjame tomar el color
morado este lado que mide 5 este lado
que mide 5
es correspondiente al lado que se ha
opuesto al ángulo morado en el triángulo
grande es decir ese lado es
correspondiente a todo este lado a todo
este lado grandote al lado grandote que
mide x más 5 y este lado que mide 6 que
voy a pintar en color amarillo
corresponde a este ángulo amarillo y por
lo tanto corresponde en la semejanza a
este lado de acá que también voy a
pintar en color amarillo de esta forma
podemos utilizar la semejanza para
plantear una ecuación tenemos tenemos
que 5 dividido entre x 55 dividido entre
x más cinco esa razón es igual a la
razón de la dos correspondientes ahora
con otro color entonces fue del pequeño
al grandote entonces podemos hacer lo
mismo tomando ahora el lado amarillo con
el lado amarillo de acá entonces cinco
entre x más 5 es igual a 6 es igual a 6
entre 12 y de aquí podemos obtener el
valor de x como sigue multiplicamos por
12 de ambos lados 5 por 12 es igual a 60
entonces tenemos que 60 es igual a y
ahora multiplicamos por x 5 de ambos
lados sería 6x
x + 6 x 5 o sea 30 restamos 30 de ambos
lados nos queda que 30 es igual a 6x y
dividiendo entre 6 de ambos lados nos
queda que x es igual a 5 x es igual a 5
lo voy a poner por acá x es igual a 5
muy bien entonces utilizando la
semejanza pudimos determinar el valor de
x espero que te hayan servido estos
ejercicios de triángulos semejantes y
nos vemos hasta la próxima